[Music]
the United States is much stronger than
Russia and will be for the rest of my
professional lifetime and I would guess
for the entirety of the 21st century
unless we commit a series of almost
unimaginable self-inflicted wounds the
United States first of all has a much
larger economy our economy is now about
17 trillion dollars Russia's is less
than 2 trillion and has actually been
declining in recent years so we're
already you know close to 8 or 9 10
times stronger economically the United
States is much more powerful militarily
we spend 4 or 5 times more than Russia
does on defense every year we have much
more sophisticated weaponry than Russia
does the United States is still blessed
with allies in many parts of the world
these allies are for the most part rich
relatively powerful and stable we're
talking about countries like Germany
Japan the United Kingdom and others
Russia by contrast has no allies of any
real consequence it has something of a
friendly relationship with China but
it's not really an alliance and lastly
Russia has a terrible demographic
situation its population is much older
than ours on average and it's aging
rapidly population is projected to
decline dramatically by 30 or 40 million
people over the next 50 years or so so
for all of those reasons the United
States has far more power potential last
but not least Russia's only real
economic asset now is oil and gas people
are not lining up to buy the next
Russian smartphone or anything like that
so Russia's long-term potential strikes
me as not nearly as promising as that of
the United States
well weaker States can still do a lot of
things that cause trouble and what
Russia did in 2016 election the full
extent of which and the importance of
which we are still trying to figure out
certainly has roiled American politics
in a variety of ways so it does show
that you know even much weaker powers
can find
various ways to interfere or cause
problems and now it was in part because
we were vulnerable to that kind of
manipulation and that's our fault not
theirs I'd say a little bit more about
this too though I mean what Russia did
is not unprecedented the United States
has interfered in democratic elections
and lots of countries around the world
and you could argue that we've been
doing a variety of things to try and
encourage democratic forces promote
civil society both in Russia or in
countries close to Russia in ways that
they regard as alarming we might think
that we're doing the right thing
spreading our values in various places
but you can certainly understand how
Russia might regard that as threatening
and might even view what they did in
2016 as a form of payback you know if
you want to manipulate politics in
Ukraine if you want to interfere in
Russia in various ways well we can do
things to you as well so again without
knowing the full extent of what Russia
may or may not have done we shouldn't
view this as unprecedented and we
shouldn't view it as coming completely
out of the blue doesn't mean we have to
like it but it's important I think to
keep just how you know heinous it may or
may not be in some context here again
Russia is simply not the kind of global
superpower that the Soviet Union was it
doesn't pose a significant ideological
challenge to us it seems to me and to
the extent that the United States is
going to worry about a rival peer
competitor it's not going to be Russia
it's going to be China but having said
dad you can't imagine circumstances
where our confrontation between the two
countries could begin to spin out of
control
conceivably over what's happening in
Syria if things in Ukraine were to heat
up again and the United States got more
actively involved there one could
imagine some kind of clash arising I
don't think that leaders in Washington
or leaders in Moscow actually want
something like that to happen remember
we are still talking about two nuclear
power
with thousands of nuclear weapons that
could still be fired at each other but I
don't think you can completely rule it
out will it become like the Cold War no
I don't think so but it is something I
think that bear is watching and it's
also unfortunate in a different sense
because there are still some issues
whether its counterterrorism how to deal
with Iran what to do about the civil war
in Syria where collaboration with Russia
might be useful and one last point if we
really are worried about China over the
long term if that's really the rising
power that we need to keep our eye on
the last thing we should be doing is
anything that drives Moscow closer to
Beijing Russia and China when you look
at just the geography here are not
really natural allies they have many
reasons to be wary of one another and we
should in fact be trying to get Moscow
to be more on our side and less on
China's side over the long term so
spitting up a new cold war with Russia
doesn't make a whole lot of sense from a
larger strategic perspective